seit beginn der menschheit betrachten
wir die sterne und verspüren das
bedürfnis neue orte zu entdecken
wir fragen uns was es dort draußen gibt
inzwischen wissen wir schon eine menge
über die welt da draußen
wir wissen wie gefährlich das weltall
ist wie unbarmherzig die umgebung auf
anderen planeten für lebewesen wie uns
ist und trotzdem wollen wir gehen nasa
esa jaxa spacex und blue origin alle
haben sie pläne im nächsten jahrzehnt
zum mond zu fliegen und dort eine
dauerhafte präsenz zu errichten
der mond eignen sich perfekt um das
leben im weltraum zu erproben und könnte
zusätzlich noch als sprungbrett zu
fernen planeten dienen also leben wir
bald auf dem mond
dieses video hier entsteht in
zusammenarbeit mit dem youtube kanal
raumzeit wie lockt der zukunft die jungs
machen auf ihrem kanal extrem viele
coole videos zum thema weltall und alles
was damit zu tun hat dass sie ist der
erste teil unserer kooperation und auf
ihrem kanal gibt es dann nach meinem
video den zweiten teil viel spaß
[Musik]
erfolgen
bayer bringen
1969 setzte neil armstrong als erster
mensch einen fuß auf die oberfläche des
mondes ein meilenstein für die raumfahrt
in den folgenden drei jahren fanden fünf
weitere bemannte mondmissionen statt
doch nach dem weltraum wettrennen
zwischen der sowjetunion und den usa
verlor man das interesse am mond es ging
nie darum als erster auf den mond zu
landen um ihn zu besiedeln
vielmehr war es ein kräftemessen eine
art zurschaustellung der fähigkeiten
zweier nationen
seitdem landet nur noch sondern auf dem
erdtrabanten und schnell wurde der mond
uninteressant und man konzentrierte sich
lieber auf andere himmelskörper bis 2008
da hat die indische sonde chandrayaan-1
ein paar interessante messungen
durchgeführt
entgegen vieler vermutungen konnte die
sonde die existenz von gefrorenem wasser
beweisen und seitdem wird ausgiebig über
eine basis auf dem mond diskutiert die
nasa plant bereits 2024 zum mond
zurückzukehren und ab 2028 eine
dauerhafte präsenz auf dem mond
aufzubauen
dafür hat sie bereits zusätzliches
budget gefordert die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa und die
japanische weltraumorganisation jaxa
interessieren sich ebenfalls sehr für
ein solches projekt und könnten
unterstützend mitwirken
genauso will das privat
raumfahrtunternehmens blue origin mit
amazon chef jeff bezos mit der nasa
zusammen arbeiten und hat sogar bereits
konkrete pläne vorgestellt
nur das private raumfahrtunternehmen
spacex scheint eigene pläne zu haben
sie wollen die sogenannte moonbase alpha
bauen und in typischer in masken
angekündigte des pays ex chef page speed
an
bereits im jahr 2025 starten zu wollen
die kosten für so eine mondbasis werden
auf circa 15 bis 35 milliarden euro
geschätzt das entspricht etwa dem
budgetüberschuss von deutschland im jahr
2017 und nur einem viertel der
bisherigen kosten der internationalen
raumstation eine vergleichsweise geringe
investition doch lässt sich der bau
einer mondbasis eigentlich rechtfertigen
betrachten wir den mond an sich ändert
er einer kargen einöde die vielen der
atmosphäre setzt alles tödliche
strahlung aus asteroiden schlagen
ungehindert auf der oberfläche ein
die landschaft erlitt dadurch einem
schlachtfeld und ist mit kratzern
übersät
manche kaum größer als ein haus andere
so tief wie der marianengraben ein
weiterer wesentlicher unterschied zur
erde ist die dauer eines tag nacht
zyklus auf dem mond dauert einen tag
circa 27 er tage dann herrschen dort
temperaturen von bis zu 150 grad celsius
während der langen nächte jedoch sinken
diese werte auf bis zu minus 150 grad
herab die temperaturunterschiede
zwischen tag und nacht sind so hoch dass
es nicht selten zu mond beben kommt die
gründe für eine besiedlung des mondes
müssen also sehr gut sein und es gibt
hauptsächlich zwei davon geringer
schwerkraft und bodenschätze und man
nimmt an dass der mond entstanden ist
als ein kleiner planet in den jungen
jahren des sonnensystems mit der erde
kollidiert ist die mondoberfläche hat
nämlich ein ähnliches rohstoffvorkommen
wie die erdkruste
so lässt sich massenhaft silizium
aluminium eisen und sogar titan finden
auf dem mond gibt es außerdem wertvolles
helium 3
daraus lässt sich treibstoff oder
vielleicht irgendwann einmal in
fusionsreaktoren strom gewinnen
nebenbei gibt es auch noch eine große
anzahl an anderen elementen die sehr gut
mit sauerstoff verbrennen sogar zur
nachhaltigkeit kann der mond etwas
beitragen
rohstoffe die auf der erde knapp werden
und durch ihren abbau die umwelt
belasten könnten in zukunft auf dem mond
oder auf asteroiden abgebaut werden und
zur erde transportiert werden
das starten von raketen verbraucht bei
einem start auf dem mond nämlich viel
weniger treibstoff weil die raketen
gegen gerade mal einen sechstel der
schwerkraft ankämpfen müssen in der tat
wäre es einfacher ein objekt vom mond in
die umlaufbahn der erde zu befördern als
von der erde selbst und das obwohl die
distanz ungefähr 1000 mal so groß ist
potenziell macht das den mond zu einem
riesigen warenlager für zukünftige
weltraummissionen vielleicht sogar eines
tages mit eigener werft der bau von
raumschiffen und anderen großen
strukturen wird auf dem mond nämlich
ebenfalls vereinfacht fertigungsschritte
werden billiger und weniger aufwendig zu
guter letzt wäre
eine mondbasis auch einfach eine super
möglichkeit zu testen wie wir eine basis
auf anderen planeten wie zum beispiel
dem mars aufbauen würden
auf dauer wollen wir zu einer
interplanetaren spezies werden und das
weltall erkunden und dafür müssen wir
erfahrungen sammeln
eine mondbasis wäre quasi eine erste
feuerprobe für das leben im weltall
ok der mond hat also durchaus ein
enormes potenzial für die zukunft der
menschen
doch wie plant man überhaupt so eine
kolonialisierung eines mondes der erste
schritt beinhaltet die erkundung des
mondes
allerdings waren wir schon mehrfach dort
haben mit hilfe von sonden karten
erstellt und konnten gesteinsproben
entnehmen die hier auf der erde
genauestens untersucht wurden
diesen schritt haben wir also eigentlich
schon abgehakt der nächste schritt ist
die errichtung eines außenpostens am
besten eignen sich dafür die pole
die das eis beherbergen die ersten
menschen werden größtenteils
wissenschaftler sein
sie werden wege erproben auf dem mond zu
überleben enorm wichtig für eine
unabhängige kolonie ist die
eigenversorgung mit sauerstoff wasser
und nahrung sauerstoff und wasser lassen
sich direkt aus dem boden gewinnen
dort befinden sich nämlich sauerstoff
isotope und das gefrorene wasser
fleischliebhaber werden auf dem mond
leider nicht glücklich werden
darum wird es vorerst nur ein
pflanzlicher form geben da tiere eine
menge futter und wasser benötigen zwei
sachen die es auf den nicht gerade im
überfluss gibt deshalb gibt es
zahlreiche forschungsprojekte pflanzen
unter künstlichem licht und mit einem
geringen wasserverbrauch wachsen zu
lassen
alle prozesse zur versorgung der kolonie
sind sehr energie lässt sich der dazu
benötigte strom wird vorerst auf
solarenergie gewonnen werden
das ist auch der grund dafür dass man
den außenposten während der ersten
monate wahrscheinlich noch verlassen
muss solarzellen können nicht genug
strom bereitstellen um die 13 tage
langen nächte zu überbrücken
auf dauer muss deshalb eine andere art
der energiegewinnung her
besonders attraktiv ist dabei natürlich
die fusionsenergie sie liefert eine
nahezu unendliche quelle an sauberer
energie
wer sich darüber näher informieren
möchte klickt gerne hier
aber ob man wirklich schon in 10 oder 20
jahren mit fusionsenergie auf dem mond
arbeiten kann
ist fraglich einen streitpunkt stellt
bisher noch die art der unterkünfte da
sowohl esa als auch nasa erforschen
momentan die möglichkeit mondgestein mit
einem 3d drucker zu nutzen
so sollen vor der kolonialisierung 3d
drucker auf den mond geschickt werden
die dann schicht für schicht den staub
des mondes in bewohnbarer habitate
verwandeln unterkünfte aus mondstein
brauchen jedoch mit sofern nicht anders
isoliert fünf bis sechs meter dicke
wände um die bewohner vor der strahlung
zu schützen
das problem kann umgangen werden indem
man unterirdisch baut der mond besitzt
riesige untergrund tunnel durch die
einmal frühjahr war geflossen ist diese
bieten genug platz um eine kolonie oder
ganze städte zu beherbergen
dort ist es zwar immer dunkel aber man
setzt wegen der langen tages zyklen
wahrscheinlich sowieso auf künstliches
licht wenn das alles läuft dann kommt
der letzte schritt und der ist besonders
spannend denn wenn die kolonie nicht
mehr auf die hilfe der erde angewiesen
ist dann ist sie per definition selbst
erhalten
die kolonie benutzt dann materialien des
mondes und exportiert diese vielleicht
sogar zur erde
dadurch wird die ökonomisch produktiv
und wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwann
unabhängig vielleicht gibt es irgendwann
sogar eine mond staat es ihnen sich
dienstleister private unternehmen und
arbeiter an die ihre eigenen interessen
verfolgen
während wir die erste mondbasis in den
nächsten zehn vielleicht zwanzig jahren
errichten werden ist es noch unklar wann
genau diese unabhängigkeit funktionieren
wird
jedenfalls lässt mich die vorstellung
dass ich das unter umständen noch
miterleben kann
voller vorfreude in die zukunft blickt
danke dir für das spannende video
nachdem er nun ganz vielfältige gründe
gehört habt warum eine mondbasis ist
eine gute idee ist machen wir uns doch
ein wenig die hände schmutzig und
vergaben sie ellenbogen tiefem und starb
wie genau eine erste mondbasis entstehen
kann und mit welchen lebensfeindlichen
bedingungen das geschehen muss das
erfahrt ihr im zweiten teil auf unserem
kanal raumzeit block der zukunft ich bin
ronny und ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr
vorbeischaut danke an billig doktor
watson für die spannende zusammenarbeit
und in diesem sinne 42 danke die ronny
vielen dank fürs zuschauern schaut auf
jeden fall bei ihm auf dem kanal vorbei
und wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]